[Music]  belief in oneself is contagious we are  part of something larger we are fighting  for the broke my name is dr. le staple  and I'm a psychiatrist I specialize in  those individuals who believe they are  supernatural beings I don't belong here  David Daniel do you believe you are  exceptionally strong but there are men  who are as strong as you  Kevin window.chrome you believe there  are two dozen souls living in that body  with you you can call me Norma Elijah  crisis you have an extraordinary IQ you  think you are superhuman what if I  suggested that you are mistaken they've  been lying to us all  [Music]  you were sent here to be an avenging  angel how much do you want to avenge us  these individuals have lost their  perspective a lot of people going to get  hurt don't do this you can convince the  world we exist  [Music]  are you ready  this is where they would paint you with  big eyes and bubbles of confusion above  your head  [Music]  you